Honeypot can be low or high interaction.
A low interaction honeypot typically,
emulates some network services,
such as the web server.
For example,
you can speak the HTTP protocol.
On the other hand,
it is not a full version of the service.
For example, the emulated web server
does not have all the web content and
server side programs.
A low interaction honeypot is typically
sufficient to detect network skin and
probe and imminent attacks.
On the other hand, a sophisticated
attacker may realize that
these services are not full version and
probably are not real.
A high interaction honeypot, essentially
replicates what what a real server or
work station has in terms of operating
systems, services and applications.
In other words,
they look really realistic and
they can be deployed alongside with
the real servers and work stations.
Since a high induction honeypot mimics a
real server and workstation, an attacker
may be attacking it for a long time
without knowing it is a honeypot.
Therefore, we can learn
more about the attacks.
On the other hand, it is also quite
challenging to make a honeypot
look like a real server and workstation.
For example,
we must emulate user activities and
never traffic on honeypot and
this requires
a significant amount of programming
effort as well as data storage.